hi there YouTube my name is John Green
I'm one half of the vlogbrothers along
with my brother Hank hi Hank
Hank and I live on opposite sides of the
country now that YouTube comes in
widescreen I can show you approximately
where we live Hank lives here and I live
here just by living opposite side the
country our offices look really really
similar which I never noticed before for
the past few years John and I have been
bridging that distance by communicating
through video blogs on YouTube but this
project hasn't been just about us for a
long time now we're here today to
introduce some of our favorite videos
from the 2008 project for awesome an
annual event in the holiday season when
tens of thousands of youtubers come
together to bring attention to
charitable organizations throughout the
world what I love about the project for
awesome is not only that it reminds us
that the true spirit of this season is
giving but also that it allows me to
quickly and efficiently deal with all my
present buying for instance one of the
videos that we're featuring today is
Heifer International an organization
that allows people like me to buy
animals for people like my brother Hank
awesome I would like a platypus or maybe
a liger a likert would be amazing well
actually I'm not buying an animal for
you I'm buying an animal for you that
goes to someone who needs it yeah okay I
I kind of had my heart set on that like
err
but this is good too and the coolest
part is you don't even have to buy a
full animal you can buy a particular
part of an animal for instance Hank this
year for Christmas I'm going to tell you
in advance that I got you five llama
butts now admittedly for the price of
five llama butts I could have gotten you
a llama but I didn't want to get you a
llama I wanted you to get a lot of llama
but anyway YouTube was extremely
extremely extremely extremely kindness
you to allow us to become guest editors
of the front page for a day so we've
taken this responsibility extremely
seriously we haven't put any of our on
videos up like Oprah did that one time
and we haven't just chosen people who
are our best friends though our parents
made a video and I we we included that
one I mean they're our parents we owe
them a lot but rest assured the decision
was extremely difficult and I feel very
guilty about not putting some of the
really amazing project for awesome
videos on the front page that I could
put on the front page so you should
probably just search around for project
for awesome videos because there are
lots that are really amazing that didn't
get featured in the front page I'd like
to thank all the people who we know as
nerdfighters who helped make this
project such a success and
to say thanks to everyone who's watching
us inside this box for watching a video
that's not about Turkish soccer or
waterskiing squirrels but most of all we
want to thank you for checking out the
project for awesome videos and for
considering to give your time and money
to people and organizations who do
things because they're just the right
thing to do this is Hank green of the
vlogbrothers don't forget to be awesome